what's up guys I'm Tina mojo and I'm
here at BuzzFeed today promoting my MTV
nofilter show season 2 airings February
4th on MTV's YouTube channel and today
I'm going to be playing the puppies and
answering fan questions oh oh my god I'm
pregnant oh my god she's something come
here to hurt a lot comes to mind I think
a lot of them hold there are ones that
hold really special places in my heart
even like my wedding video and stuff
like that but at the same time like
there's ones like wooden Billy Eilish
unfollowed me like turning something
like that and did just like something
like heart and light-hearted and funny
was a fun experience for me they all
definitely hold like different places in
my heart david dobrik and i guess was
shane dawson as much as i've done it
he's still just like my favorite person
on earth the two of them together really
funny thing to say - i feel like all of
my answers are so quintessential but
it's always Shane Dawson anything I've
ever made with him is like that was the
peak of my life it will never get better
but I'm doing a lot of upcoming stuff
with some traditional celebrities that I
really really really with can I say quit
on BuzzFeed oh and I'm really excited
about that so prepare something is every
answer Shane Dawson I suck it all does
root from Shane as well but at the same
time I just said it wasn't really a
person in specifics it was more of a
desire to turn like darkness in my life
into like light in someone else's if I
could make anyone else happy for like
five minutes of the day especially from
the bad guy laundry that's it
what I wanted to do I don't know if I do
I definitely spent a lot of my life
being a very distraction oriented person
and I would always try to like bounce
back I'm like bounce back that way but
now I feel like it's all about loving
yourself
Jake and I were always supposed to do
that it definitely would be fun but
maybe Jay Alvarez be fine come on Jase
fine crying
unhappy working a job that I hated
watching YouTube and all my time I
definitely know oh she's like eating my
makeup sorry he's so calm she's like me
is she high I don't even know I would
hope that I would find something when I
was equally as passionate about but it's
very hard because I I love you more than
anything she needs me I'm gonna let her
do her thing
I'm sorry Queen go live your best life I
swear to god it's gross at this point
but anything either Shane or Paris has
ever said to me I feel like both of them
really rude a lot of their advice around
authenticity and I think in moments of
my career Popoff Queen in moments of my
career where I definitely needed people
to remind me to stay on the path of
being nothing but myself I think that
those are two people I always really
look to so I think Shane has been there
for me giving me the most like pivotal
advice I've ever really needed during
like the darkest times in my career stop
not to make a puppy interview dark leave
it to me to do that I think that even
the things that like you know could be
deleted we're all learning lessons and
made me who I am today so I don't know
maybe prinos job veneer me she wasn't
very cute I mean obviously I think
everything online you have to take with
a grain of salt because it's like it's
someone through a computer telling you
that and it's like those people were
having like their worst moments aired
for the world to judge on it would be
like the same sorry it would be the same
situation so I mean obviously I think I
was talking about this the other day if
you get a lot of the same negative
comment I try to look at things like
that as constructive criticism and make
me better but if it's just sound right
hate I feel like especially in the space
that I'm in the love outweighs they hate
and I definitely just want to focus know
oh I mean there was it for a while there
were forums for like months that were
like all of these people conspiracy I
thing I think that's how you say that I
was secretly 40 and hiding it and all of
this likes proof s4 like how I'm
secretly 40 and it was kind of
believable like if it wasn't me I would
probably believe the conspiracy theory
but this week people think I'm pregnant
with a list of islands baby which makes
no sense so many moments that I look
back back in the day and I'm just like
you stupid you should have been longing
that there's so many things that I
definitely could have logged I really if
I wasn't logging it it's probably really
bad and I shouldn't have been so many
people saying nothing to that one
because now we record everything whether
it's on the show or on my youtube
channel or what it's all out there I
love a good Disney moment honestly my
last video is one of the dizziest videos
I've ever uploaded like girl if you're
losing a tooth in Miami like drunk for
five days like I missed the Superbowl
like that is so not cute it's single
Tana single Tana scares even me and
apparently this dog don't throw a
convention girl you super don't have to
do that the best learning experiences
for me are always the ones that are by
going through it I always learned that
everybody taking like the the hard rope
which is sad but that's just like my
life so I don't know maybe I would just
tell younger means to love herself and
to be really authentic and to not look
for love in the wrong places
dark keeping this puppy interview real
dark
how can I give this to mr. meeseeks
what's his mailing address it's very
crazy to think that like that many
people like typed in my name and voted
for me to like win that it was seeing
all of the love like my fans give me
every day in such a tangible way and I
was so so grateful for it I'm still
shocked by it I look at that whole
moment it's just like a dream I don't
know
oh that's stepping on my nipple but I
love it I'm definitely gonna leave the
cosmetic brands to Kylie and Jeffrey
right now but if they want to collab hi
I'm right here please give me a pallet
Jefferey please I'm more of a clothing
type of girl so I would love to see some
clothing and fashion stuff coming up
next guys these adorable puppies were
provided by Vanderpump dogs so for more
information on that and all the
adoptions don't like that the link is
below
[Music]
[Music]